il est fier et heureux
dany laferrière manifestement incapable
de contenir sa joie
dans ma famille on n'a pas l'habitude de
laisser l'étiquette sous le cadeau donc
quand on est heureux on fait savoir
à 62 ans il est sur le point d'être reçu
dans le club très sélect de l'académie
française parmi ceux qu'on appelle des
immortels un québécois de haye
c'est une espèce d'horaires l'académie
est une institution plusieurs fois
centenaires anti de riddes et de
traditions comme s'est amusé elle
rappelé avec humour
l'écrivain jean d'ormesson l'académie
est une famille naturellement on se
déteste entre nous mais quelquefois
aussi on s'aime beaucoup parmi les
traditions celle de l'épée de
l'académicien nous sommes tous les
frères je t'embrasse
je te remets ton effet dany laferrière a
voulu que la sienne viennent d'haïti
alors que son costume officiel lui a été
confectionnée au québec
un choix à l'image de sa double identité
comme je ne cesse de le dire si je suis
né en haïti
je suis ni écrivain au québec de fait
dany laferrière est le premier québécois
à être reçu à l'académie
le commandant donne l'exemple de ce
qu'ils vont faire pour le français
et souvent nous avons un bureau en
france de voir que le français est
plus et mieux défendue aux paladins en
france même
dany laferrière va plus loin il ne se
borne pas à défendre la langue
il prend plaisir à la faire évoluer avec
tous les mots en créole dont il parsème
ses romans et les mots québécois qu'il a
déjà entrepris de faire connaître aux
membres de l'académie qui commençait à
parler à dire des mots et québécois qui
ont charmé l'assistance comme épinards
des comment fille roi paix comme data ou
minet et aussi des expressions aussi et
qui ont désarmé et donc il fallait les
prononcer ou qu'elles arrivent à leurs
oreilles
maintenant en possession de son épée
dany l'intérieur va pouvoir être reçus
de façon solennelle jeudi à l'académie
française
plus que deux jours d'attentes avant de
devenir à son tour un immortel et si
jean françois bélanger radio canada
barry